delle bevande e non sapevo in che modo
partita challenge ne abbiamo
approfittato perché amanti siamo stati
alla fiera dei videogiochi e abbiamo
trovato un sacco di bibite queste sono
fatta con fattori diversi che vede già
fare la ruota quindi messo di prenderli
tutti questi sapori e andiamo a fare
questa challenge o si lesse il gioco
visto che ovviamente come sempre questa
sala è partita dall america ho visto che
qualche canale italiano attorno e cruz
non solo come la piantagione da
grandissimi di farlo seno appunto i
sapori dalla ruota alta di uno l'avrebbe
fatte dalla ruota dove andremo ad
assaggiarle e poi andiamo a mischiarle
e alla fine andiamo bene tutte iniziate
dopo le hanno senso che stanco tifoso
non lo so vedremo
le altre challenge a steve lasciare
ombre like it be alive andranno 40 le
tastiere consigliata su quelli dei
commenti che sono perché durante questo
mi piace di più ecco come vorresti
assaggiare che paga non dovreste
assodato mi interessa molto meno avrei
rischiato perché scrivere ma damato
schifo è che io resti della pesca e
quello che non vorrei assaggiare
sicuramente ruba
[Musica]
ok
eccolo qua ora lo posso vedere bene ok
guardare questa fanta avuto che abbiamo
provato prima vediamo come va resto per
mercato
[Musica]
eccolo con dio tutti quelli che tipo
bene e io ho dato io credo un valore mai
raviola sa tipo di big pharma tipo di
caramella di frittelle stranissima un po
chimica che a me non è eccezionale
completa molto bene via abbiamo l'altra
prima della nel mix come lo chiamiamo il
casinò e cantare una vela bevande
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dovete bicchiere bene il suo cuore è
meglio dell'or.sa tipo di caramella
kingkan organo nella finta metti nel
calderone via
[Musica]
ecco quasi a studiare come quella alla
fragola
ecco qua è tutto sta anche questa avrà
un colore di formaggio puzzolente che è
addio
guardate e supera sia il colore rosso
per il motore per questo non mi piace
moltissimo super dolls mischia nel
calderone
[Musica]
no penso prima vale dai vada a vedere
proprio non mi piace non sentire una
buonissima inverso trasforma intaccate
verrà messo peggio per tenere sotto 70
delle libertà vendite è sì facciamo la
crescente non so perché questa mini che
sono fresco ne pensi che un po strane
beh come al sapore ammette il produttore
molto dolce mi piace marittima
ok mi piace davvero a calderone ma lei
sa
[Musica]
ok adagiatevi prima lo fa tipo di
caramella sopra zuccherosa oddio maroni
maroni brandizzo
[Musica]
l'abbiamo provata per cui ora che fatica
anche a me per te la lattina medico
arancione chiaro se pesca appunto che
colore è questo il momento di scolari ha
futuro se tipo arancio fosforescente
sono spaziosi queste si possono bene ora
dobbiamo 20 commemoriamo questa è questo
è l'ultimo video tutorial molto forte
tipo di pesca di teano testa per ora
prima sempre cecchinato dirlo da con
chimico vai vai vecchia migliore è stato
meta al marroncino timoria
[Musica]
io non l'ho provata quindi sono curioso
di provarla colore giallo andiamo crede
mi piace questa frase quello che mi
piace di più perché è molto dolce
[Applauso]
[Musica]
diventa sempre di qui dove lo devo dare
tutto
[Musica]
nella meraviglia per me è ancora più o
che io io non propriamente una parabola
[Musica]
di un fumetto alla struttura di a limone
aggiungiamo al calderone
[Musica]
pinter fragola e rosso ma anche il
formato da normale quello molliccio
[Musica]
e a due no
per fortuna gravi per ben due volte
valentino due volte mi è capitato come
la che non abbiamo ancora aperto guarda
troppo è la lattina trovarla fretta
dalla polizia a motore stranamente
abbiamo il cuore a benzina buona mi
piace
[Musica]
è che buona parte di piazza non è molto
forte
proprio ciò siamo quasi arrivati alla
fine del canone rom e quindi manca poco
[Musica]
bastano più colesterolo
e allora di ricarica
no no no no no a questo cuore diciamo
[Musica]
basta che meno che non è cambiata tanto
ma non serve un fianco ultimo giro
[Musica]
io me la vedo
era l'unica studio 100 per me
potete vedere una mia non è invidia il
nostro cane una mentalità campagna salva
guardarsi con
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non vivere tutte queste domande grassato
tutti perché fanno malissimo
quindi vai prego pertanto se noi che
possa tenere per te bella brutta di
bevande mister
inter colore delizioso oddio tipo se
vivi marrone
[Musica]
stranissimo al rissa poi sembra che si
siano anni mutarli riesco ancora a
sentire il sapore del manager iper dolce
non sappiamo se è la favola
insomma spiegarvi che sia pure a pavia
che tipo acido e borsone che al tatto
sembra fatta tanta formale io comunque è
stata quella che desta di più quella che
mi è piaciuto di più un melo melo che
sembrava un po un silo di me
sembra voglia di meno quella di meno
fragola appare anche futura guerra
pessima a me per di più fresca e quella
meno ma allora cosa fare mi conventi
quali altri challenge potete vedere
quale fissare incontri che facciamo
insieme ad esse di bombe d'acqua fresca
nel milan avrà quando quadratini schio
potete cliccare per vedere i prossimi
video the cliccare su uno di questi
quadratini per vedere le altre challenge
che abbiamo insieme divertenti blog
quello che volete cui calessino vostra
preferita
[Musica]
ciao ciao